there are more than 40 skyscrapers in
central Frankfort at 259 meters the
Comets bunk tower is the tallest the
European Central Bank's new headquarters
are east of the city center the two
towers 185 meters at their highest point
are linked by a low-rise glass atrium
food in Frankfurt it's been embraced by
the people of Frankfurt when I roll into
the city by train or see it from afar I
think now I'm home again it's finished
so how's innovative architecture and
good old goethe on a pedestal frankfurt
lives from its contrasts its historical
heart is the home aback the area with
its 600 year old town hall was almost
completely rebuilt after suffering
severe damage during World War two
nearby Frankfurt Cathedral was called an
imperial Cathedral because from more
than two centuries the rulers of the
Holy Roman Empire were chosen and
crowned here Johann Wolfgang von Goethe
was born in this house in 1749 oh wow
these are the original stairs that
Goethe's family and Goethe actually
walked on you can see the styles worn
when he was just 25 Goethe wrote the
novella the sorrows of young Vata here
it caused the sensation there are many
museums along the banks of the river
mine the stadle Art Museum has been here
for 200 years in its anniversary year
it's showing 50 paintings by the French
impressionist Claude Monet there is a
special underground gallery for
contemporary art I think it's pretty
cool I really like the round skylights
because they let in so much natural
light find food
the combination of new and old is
exciting in the state as well its
collection contains paintings from seven
centuries they can be seen on the walls
as originals and in the digital
collection it allows the state all to
present its masterpieces online by the
end of the year some 1500 works should
be available for viewing with lots of
additional information and suggestions
if you enter the word sword for instance
you get all the pictures that have a
sword in them I don't think it can be
compared to visiting a museum in any way
it's a completely different experience
this is primarily a form of
communication in the form of definitely
the museum's own app supplies quick and
concise information it recognises major
works from the collection in the museum
itself but can also be called up outside
of the building
Frankfurt's Klein Matala is a fabulous
indoor market local shop here and
tourists get to taste Hessian
specialties it's a very popular stop on
guided tours of the city
we have never tried con quesa myth music
haunt kaiza is a pungent sour milk
cheese it's usually eaten with caraway
seeds its name translates literally as
hand cheese because it's shaped by hand
it's served with a dressing which is the
music in the name of the dish but what
does it have to do with music music is
sin dressing with vinegar oil and onions
and it's said that this onions make
music in your body hand Kaiser is eaten
with bread and butter but never with a
fork Bon Appetit
you